ici pousse l'un des bâtiments dédiés à
la santé mentale depuis mars 2016 le
site médical de la mgen la verrière
poursuit sa mue quarante mille mètres
carrés de surface plancher un
investissement de 100 millions d'euros
donc c'est pour la mgen un très gros
chantier
le chantier c'est un chantier à haute
qualité environnementale effectivement
la certification d étude a été faite
et puis nous avançons et aujourd'hui sur
la réalisation avec une maîtrise des
nuisances au niveau du chantier
un chantier qui permet de fusionner les
deux sites historiques marcel rivière et
denis forestier jugé vétuste
la livraison du bâtiment santé mentale
est prévue pour la fin de l'année 2018
le centre de me forestier lui continue
son activité tels codes lui ne viendra
comme je le disais précédemment qu'à la
fin la réalisation on l'a on transfère à
l'ensemble de nos patients et de nos
résidents nous avons la chance également
que toute la production restauration est
située sur le site rj arias tombe des
nues forissier donc on continue à livrer
la restauration du premier site comme
celui là si tu mens et la rivière sans
aucun impact pour nous pour nos patients
les travaux sont prévus sur trois ans
fin 2019 le site aura 4 185 lits ses 76
de plus qu'auparavant